foreign
[Music]
story tonight concerns crime Batman's
adversary and also his Kink come on you
think someone dresses in a rubber suit
just to avenge their parents he's a
furry with a gadget belt grow up now
with the midterm elections fast
approaching tough on crime rhetoric has
been a key feature of Republican attack
ads often highlighting one policy in
particular bail reform do you feel safe
Mandela Barnes would eliminate cash bail
setting accused criminals free into the
community before trial landsman wants to
end cash bail putting dangerous
criminals back on the Street Beasley
supports ending cash bail letting
criminals out of jail using cashless
bail and his own Lawless policies Bragg
has put violent criminals back on our
streets and has turned neighborhoods
into danger zones okay of course
everything seems scarier if you end it
with a shot of a body bag for instance
Doc McStuffins not a scary show but if
they didn't episode said in the
McStuffins morgue it's going to have
nightmares for a while now these attack
ads come at a crucial juncture for the
movement to reduce the use of cash bail
because since 2011 at least 19 States
and dozens of local jurisdictions have
adopted bail reform policies but many
places have recently begun rolling back
those reforms because amid the recent
spike in certain categories of crime
critics are pointing at bail reform as
the major cause of it liberal lawmakers
ended the bail for most offenses they
created a revolving door of criminality
it's almost impossible to get arrested
and then put in jail unless you kill
somebody it is baffling to me that we
have politicians that aren't supporting
policies that are going to make things
better in fact they're doing the
opposite we're still supporting bail
reform and defunding the police there's
a correlation between the bail reform
and what's happening in our city
it seems so clear that it is and to
destroy the country's finest Police
Department is is a crime I think on its
own
it's clear to a man with resting
concussion face
he honestly looks like he's studying a
full body mirror desperately trying to
find his penis
it's now to the point where any crime
mentioned on Fox News gets linked to
battle reform whether it is relevant or
not even after Nancy Pelosi's husband
was attacked with a hammer on Friday
morning by someone who was not out on
bail they had a republican Congressman
on to say this when you let dangerous
criminals out out on the streets you
know with bail and not put him in prison
you're just asking for this this sort of
incident to happen no he's wrong about a
few things there again the suspect was
not out on bail also no one gets bailed
out of prison that is where convicted
people go and finally choosing a narrow
tie knot when your head is that big
makes it look like a birthday balloon
sailing over the capital Dome that is
three big mistakes from that very grumpy
balloon but given that you are hearing
that misleading attacks like that
absolutely everywhere right now there is
a real chance of all the progress we've
made being undone so tonight let's look
at bail reform and this is actually our
Second Story on bail we first covered it
back in 2015 but maybe see that
particular episode because you were too
busy watching the 69th annual Tony
Awards airing the same night where and
this is true Kristen Chenoweth and Alan
[ __ ] opened the show by highlighting
one particular celebrity in the audience
and the producer of Finding Neverland
Harvey Weinstein
[Applause]
[Music]
a week box office receipts for the last
three months
[Applause]
yeah my point is it's been a minute
since then
so if you missed our first story here's
a brief recap if you are arrested in
order to be released a waiting trial
you're often required to leave a certain
amount of money or bail with the court
as collateral with the idea that it'll
help ensure that you return and there
are plenty of issues with this system
starting with the fact the bail hearings
can be arbitrary at best because one you
might assume that a judge would
carefully weigh someone's charges and
circumstances to decide whether there is
any reason that they should not be
released the reality can look very
different take this hearing in Dallas
we're going to bleep the person's last
name here but I'm going to show you her
hearing in its entirety
penny
you're here on a state jail felony theft
with previous conviction spawned at five
thousand dollars that's it that was the
whole thing and I don't know exactly how
long it should take to put a price on
someone's freedom but it probably
shouldn't fit neatly into an Instagram
story and the thing is that's not an
outlier overall it is common for bail
hearings to last only a few minutes with
no defense counsel present and they can
be conducted with Incredible pettiness
just watch this hearing from 2016 in
Harris County Texas where a woman had
been charged with a misdemeanor of
possessing less than two ounces of
marijuana
there's probable cause bond is a
thousand dollars are you requesting a
court appointed lawyer
sure
give me a yes or no
yeah
give me a yes or no
yeah I asked a question that calls for a
yes or a no I don't expect anything but
a yes or no not a maybe so or a yell or
anything yeah or something I heard what
you said your bond just went up to two
thousand dollars okay first [ __ ] all the
way off second yeah means yes it's not
only she gave you a thumbs up and wait
you knew what she meant you just wanted
to be a dick and if you cannot afford a
bail that a sassy judge felt like
dishing out to you you might be forced
to turn to a bail bondsman the way their
business model works is that they will
post your bail for you in exchange for a
fee that's normally around 10 percent of
it money by the way you don't get back
no matter what the outcome of your case
it is a lucrative business which writes
in about two billion dollars per year
almost none of which goes into their
spending on ads like these they say I
broke the law police are on my tail
looks like I'm going to the county jail
I gotta go Bail Bonds
who I called and the courtesy and
services
[Music]
you know
it's not the direction that I would have
taken for the Barbie movie but I trust
Greta go Wing's Vision on this although
credit to all three songwriters there
you can find all those tracks on now
that's what I call songs written by the
nephew of the guy who owns a bail bond
agency volume 25. but if you can't
afford to pay a bail bondsman to get you
out you are stuck and many many people
are in that situation which has led to a
truly staggering statistic this graph
shows local jail inmates in the United
States
in the past 20 years that population has
shot way up and there's something
surprising about that rise
you can see it only if you look at
inmates with convictions around 1999
that population leveled off meaning most
of the rise came from this group
non-convicted prisoners every day in the
U.S nearly half a million people sitting
in local jails haven't been convicted of
anything it's true in fact right now
roughly two-thirds of our jail
population on any given day are people
who haven't been convicted of a crime
and most of them are there because they
simply couldn't afford to bail
themselves out which is terrible we
shouldn't hold people captive in shitty
conditions simply because they can't bow
their way out that is what Spirit
Airlines is for
what all this means is that a simple
arrest even for a crime that you did not
commit can destroy your life because
even a short amount of time in jail can
completely turn it upside down and it's
often not a short amount of time take
Marvin Mayfield he was arrested for a
burglary that he insists he didn't
commit and he got stuck in Rikers for
nearly a year
before you went in you you had started a
job you had secured in a place had a car
right what happened to Oliver all of
those things my job my car and my place
were all gone after 11 months I couldn't
hold on to it it's true he was in there
for 11 months and obviously no job is
cool with you just not showing up for 11
months unless of course you're this lazy
[ __ ] and and all of this is before you
get to the fact that holding someone
pre-trial can give a prosecutor a huge
amount of Leverage in obtaining a guilty
plea again Marvin Mayfield maintains he
was innocent but he pled guilty anyway
and when you hear him explain why it
makes sense after 11 months they said
that if you plead guilty today you get
time served and go home so your option
was to stay in and fight this cave or
you can go home today but another guilty
plea another guilty plea to a felony on
my record the worst and hardest blow of
everything
let's complete guilty to something I
didn't do just to stop that suffering
and I get that if I've been held in
Rikers for 11 months with no trial and
no end in sight I confess to anything if
it meant going home Lindberg baby
snatched it JFK Captain Zodiac Killer it
me just please let me go home and yes I
can see it too there is a resemblance
except I'm kidding I look nothing like
the Zodiac Killer and you will agree
with that if you know what's good for
you
so cash bail is arbitrary destructive
and basically criminalizes poverty and
that is without getting into the massive
racial disparities involved here and
when you take all of this together you
can understand why so many jurisdictions
passed some form of bail reform over the
last few years and notably in some
places it was done with bipartisan
support in 2014 New Jersey passed a bill
that has since cut the number of people
in its jails by half and it was
championed by a surprising figure
no longer must you stay in jail for
minor offenses longer than you would
have if you would actually be convicted
of the crime
which you're accused of committing just
because your family doesn't have 500 to
post bail yeah to his real credit Chris
Christie supported by reform and
remember this is the same Chris Christie
who thought it was a good idea to be Pro
traffic jam got photographed enjoying a
beach that have been close to the public
by a government shutdown and was the
first major Republican candidate to
endorse this historic whoopsy the right
side of History has to be pretty [ __ ]
obvious if even Chris Christie can find
it and yet in many places the backlash
to these reforms has been Swift and ugly
and it always takes the same form you
saw earlier fear-mongering about how
reforming cash bail means that violent
criminals are going to be wantingly set
loose on the streets to reoffend but
every part of that is much more
complicated than it sounds for starters
a huge amount of people in jail are
stuck there on simple misdemeanors or
non-violent charges and even when it
comes to violent felony charges those
happen on a very broad spectrum from
murder to Simply Be involved in a fight
and importantly being charged with
something does not necessarily mean that
you are guilty of it that is for a trial
to decide yet too many people are only
too happy to blur the line between
charge and conviction early this year
Chicago mayor Laurie Lightfoot did
exactly that when criticizing pre-trial
release programs in Cook County which
implemented its battle reforms back in
2017. the mayor saying judges should not
allow people charged with violent crimes
to walk free on bail or electronic
monitoring because if they're charged
they're guilty
when those case charges are brought
these people are guilty and of course
they're entitled to a presumption of
innocence of course they're entitled to
their day in court but residents in our
community are also entitled to safety
hold on you can't say someone's guilty
and then say they're entitled to a
presumption of innocence those two ideas
just cannot coexist you can't be guilty
and innocent at the same time just like
you can't be hungry and full or tall and
short or British and happy it's one or
it's the other believe me
and Illinois's bail conversation has
only gotten more heated now that a
Statewide law eliminating the use of
cash bail is set to take effect in
January Republicans have called it The
Purge law and have attacked it in some
pretty gross ways including these
unusual mail list of Voters
papers they've been delivered under
different names this one the Chicago
City Wire they all claim to have real
data and real news but it's also a
campaign message not a real newspaper
there are two pages of photos of men
mostly black and Latino who according to
the paper will be released on bond into
Page County the controversial newspaper
like mailings are from Republican
strategist Dan Prof who runs the people
who play by the rules pack Wow first
that is strikingly racist and second
those mailers were complete horseshits
they say to the new law mandates murder
suspects awaiting trial be released from
jail which it does not they also feature
a list of charges that they claimed were
non-detainable but the truth is that in
Illinois as in most places that have
passed bail reform for serious and
violent crimes suspects can still be
jailed pre-trial if they are considered
a public safety risk or likely to flee
so those claims were basically the more
most misleading thing to appear in
newsprint since the idea that Dagwood
could pull Blondie come on look at him
and then look at her there's just no way
or ten and Dagwood's
to buy Funny Pages standards she married
down a long way down
and to see just how successfully Bale
reform opponents can demagogue this
issue just look here in New York the Big
cuckoo City that go honk honk this
state's male reform law took effect on
New Year's Day of 2020 and just eight
days later long before there was any
data on its impacts state legislators
were out there trying to get it repealed
I think people are getting scared I
think people are feeling unsafe and more
unsafe as each day goes by we're going
to hammer this
I want to be clear we're going to hammer
this every single day
we're going to make the point that this
is what the public cares about
that was just eight days in so unless a
ton of people chose the New Year's
resolution be scared of bail reform and
actually stuck with it past January 3rd
to equally unrealistic scenarios I'm
pretty sure that Suffolk County Carl
McLaughlin here is hammering away at
thin air and the thing is violent crime
did rise in New York in 2020 just like
it did everywhere else in America both
in places that passed by reform and in
places that didn't and yet the NYPD
relentlessly labeled bail reform the
cause it's then commissioned a Dermot
Shay repeatedly took to the press to
label it a major reason for increases in
crime and gun violence but when the New
York Post checked those claims using the
nypd's own data they found that in the
first six months of 2020 out of 528
shooting incidents exactly one had been
committed by someone released under bail
reform and that wasn't the only time
that Shea was misleading he also went on
a local Morning Show here to suggest
that the suspect in a purse snatching
was out on bail he has 11 open court
cases right now think about that how is
this allowed to how is this allowed to
continue to to to to Foster like this
well one side will say as long as he
shows up at Court then everything is
working well and I would I would say
that everything is not working well the
lemon open court cases is something that
you don't want to deal with someone that
we wouldn't want to encounter on the
streets now that may well sound scary to
you but I've got some good news they
found that guy with 11 open cases it was
actually pretty easy to do because it
turns out he was already locked up in
Rikers at the time the crime took place
so she accused the wrong guy entirely
but I'm sure New York slept much safer
knowing that that guy was safely behind
the same bars he was already behind
before just two days after that
interview Shea had to appear before the
state legislator and interestingly all
the fear-mongering and Bluster that he'd
spread on newspapers and TV completely
collapsed in a forum where he was
actually expected to answer honestly
were there people out uh who who with no
bail for example or Bill being said and
they made bail I don't know
um and then committed another shooting
and were arrested again for basically
the same crime when you look at who we
arrest for crimes it's going to be small
numbers when you look at the the
entirety of how many shooting arrests we
make and the percentage it's not
dramatic I'm sorry the percentage is not
dramatic you are constantly claiming
battle reform was driving up shootings
there are Hermits on mountaintops you
know exactly two things all of reality
is but the brief dance of light across
the water surface and Dermot Shea says
bio reform is responsible for the rising
crime in New York and you would think
he'd be embarrassed by being forced to
admit that the percentage is not
dramatic but just two months later he
was back on TV saying this is bail
reform what is leading to more shootings
100 more gun possessions happening 100
100
there is no doubt well which is it damn
it are the numbers not dramatic always
better reform 100 leading two more
shootings because those things are
mutually exclusive the only place where
not dramatic and a hundred percent can
exist at the same time is in Kristen
Stewart's whole General Vibe she's
giving it her all but she's also giving
us absolutely nothing it's totally
amazing
and the problem is all of this the
exaggerated claims and The Sensational
headlines have made a real impression on
people public approval of bail reform in
this state has plummeted and the state
legislature has now rolled back portions
of the law twice and that is the thing
it's hard to overcome the emotional
impact of the claim that bail reform
harms Public Safety and I'm not saying
that you can't find isolated instances
of individuals who have been rearrested
for new crimes while out awaiting trial
you can do that and anytime someone is a
victim of a crime that is terrible but
if Public Safety is genuinely your
priority cash bail has never
fundamentally been about that for all
the ads currently claiming that people
charged with violent crimes and now
walking the streets they always were as
long as they had enough money to make
bail under too many places current
systems a person facing a marijuana
misdemeader who doesn't have two
thousand dollars is going to get stuck
inside a jail but a Serial sex offender
who makes I don't know hypothetically a
million dollars a week in finding
Netherland receipts gets to stay at home
and when you pull back and look at the
overall figures of where the bail reform
has any statistically significant link
to crimes the answer so far has been
pretty conclusively no one analysis
looked at studies in seven different
jurisdictions and none of them found
that bail reforms lead to a meaningful
increase in crime and research has even
shown that if you can avoid
unnecessarily jailing people you can
actually reduce the likelihood of future
arrests which does make sense does it
because if you don't upend people's
lives by needlessly locking them up for
pre-trial they're in a much better
position to stay out of trouble in
Harris County Texas the place where you
saw that dick is Judge earlier
researchers found that after cash bail
was drastically reduced in their
misdemeanor courts there was actually a
six percent decrease in new prosecutions
of people over the three years following
their arrest so it works out better for
absolutely everybody but I do get that
those stats don't sound nearly as flashy
over footage of a crime scene you can't
make a crime ad that looks like this
do you feel safe you should study after
study shows bail reform has not been
linked to an increase in crime and
arrest rates pre and post-reform have
either remained identical or slightly
dropped and this dead body it's just 70
pounds of ham in the shape of a man
it's honest but it doesn't pack quite
the same punch does it and for all the
fears of letting someone who is a danger
onto the streets again Bell reform
doesn't take away judge's ability to
detain someone that they genuinely
believe to be a threat in 49 states all
except New York judges are allowed to
consider both risk of failure to appear
and Public Safety in pre-trial decisions
and even in New York it was generally
accepted judges did it anyway as
potential dangerousness has been the de
facto use of bail here for decades and
reasonable people could disagree on how
exactly to make those determinations but
one place that some experts point to as
a model is New Jersey whose system now
looks like this judge Sybil Elias is
weighing whether to free or detain a man
who appears from the county jail by
closed circuit notice there is no
mention of money for bail because the
new system eliminates that instead it
uses information such as convictions not
arrest not socioeconomic factors punched
into a computer the trial court
administrator will give each defendant a
score of one to six for risk of
reoffending and risk of skipping core
even if a defendant has a high score
prosecutors must ask for a detention
hearing within three to five days and
must present clear and convincing
evidence to detain someone yeah and that
seems pretty good right although I will
say it is by no means perfect for one
assigning people a crime score sounds
like something RoboCop does right before
he punches you out of a window and it's
worth noting computer algorithms are not
immune to buyers themselves one such
system in Broward County Florida was
particularly likely to falsely flag
black defendants as future criminals
wrongly labeling them at almost twice
the rate as white defendants it was
basically a racist computer which I
realize is probably Elon musk's next
billion dollar idea
and New Jersey's approach isn't the only
one that can work bow reform has looked
different in Harris County and in New
York but in each of those places it's
resulted in fewer people behind bars and
no negative impact on Public Safety the
point here is if we wanted to there are
multiple ways to design a system that
truly prioritizes Public Safety but if
you count the accused as part of the
public which you really should we should
be considering their safety too because
terrible things happen when you are
locked up pre-trial and it's not just
that you can lose your job and your home
you can lose your life an investigation
of over 500 U.S jails founded between
2008 and 2019 they saw over 7 500 inmate
deaths and of those people nearly 5 000
were never convicted of the charges on
which they were being held here in New
York at Rikers where most people are
held pre-trial 17 people have died this
year so far and I know this conference
station gets heated but it's important
to remember why bail reform was so
important to begin with and in thinking
about this story I'd like to share
something that has really stuck with me
because when we did our bail segment
seven years ago right until the last
minute we were going to include a clip
of Khalif Browder now if you're not
familiar with his story at 16 he was
wrongly arrested for stealing a backpack
now this was the clip that we were going
to use of him the guy comes out of
nowhere says I robbed him and the next
thing you know they put in the customer
I don't even know this dude router's
family couldn't make the ten thousand
dollars bail on the robbery charges
months turned into years he tried to
commit suicide several times in June he
was suddenly freed with no explanation
no apology no nothing they just said oh
case dismissed don't worry about nothing
like don't what do you mean don't worry
about nothing I just took over three
years of my life I didn't get to go to
prom graduation nothing it was in the
many years I'm never gonna get those
years back never
never
now we pulled that clip out of the show
just before typing when we found out
that he killed himself the night before
and his death isn't even included in any
of the tallies of people who were killed
by Rikers despite the fact it sure feels
like it should be the collateral damage
of locking so many people up pre-trial
is enormous to defend this system is to
defend a people wrecking machine
so where do we go from here well if
we're not careful we're going to go
backwards which will be a huge mistake
and I would argue that any future system
should be built on a few basic
principles first for someone charged
with a low level offense we should
prioritize letting them remain free
pre-trial instead of defaulting to
keeping them in jail second whenever any
bail hearings do happen they should be
longer than 10 seconds I cannot [ __ ]
believe that has to be said out loud
also people should have counsel with
them at bail hearings I honestly can't
believe that has to be said either and
finally if someone is detained we should
be Expediting their trial so that they
are not waiting years for a court date
I'm not saying the reform is easy or
that it's simple there are going to be
disagreements even among Advocates about
best practices here but right now we
can't even have those important
conversations because all the air in the
room is being taken up by [ __ ]
fear-mongering ads fake newspapers and
and confidently delivered lies from men
in uniform and look even after
convictions we're clearly locking far
too many people up in this country but
to do it before they've even been
convicted of anything is proof that
civil liberties only apply tangibly to
the privileged and for everyone else
they are entirely theoretical and anyone
even trying to defend a system like this
is basically morally bankrupt isn't that
right Dermot 100
100 there is no doubt yeah for once I
cannot argue with you there